[Music]
studies have shown that taking vitamins
is good for your health and bad for your
health that newly discovered herb can
improve your memory or destroy your
liver headlines proclaim a promising new
cancer treatment and never mention it
again on a daily basis we are bombarded
with attention-grabbing news backed up
by scientific studies but what are these
studies how are they performed and how
do we know whether they're reliable when
it comes to dietary or medical
information the first thing to remember
is that while studies on animals or
individual cells can point the way
towards further research the only way to
know how something will affect humans is
through a study involving human subjects
and when it comes to human studies the
scientific gold standard is the
randomized clinical trial or RCT the key
to our CTS is that the subjects are
randomly assigned to their study groups
they are often blinded to make them more
rigorous this process attempts to ensure
that the only difference between the
groups is the one the researchers are
attempting to study for example when
testing a new headache medication a
large pool of people with headaches
would be randomly divided into two
groups one receiving the medication and
another receiving a placebo with proper
randomization the only significant
overall difference between the two
groups will be whether or not they
received the medication rather than
other differences that could affect
results randomized clinical trials are
incredible tools and in fact the US Food
and Drug Administration often requires
at least two to be conducted before a
new drug can be marketed but the problem
is that an RCT is not possible in many
cases either because it's not practical
or would require too many volunteers in
such cases scientists use an
epidemiological study which simply
observes people going about their usual
behavior rather than randomly assigning
active participants to control and
variable groups let's say we wanted to
study whether an herbal ingredient on
the market causes nausea rather than
deliberately giving people something
that might make them nauseated we would
find those who already take the
ingredient in their everyday lives this
group is called the cohort we would also
need a comparison group of people who do
not have exposure to the ingredient and
we would then compare statistics if the
rate of nausea is higher in the herbal
cohort it suggests an association
between the
supplement and nausea epidemiological
studies are great tools to study the
health effects of almost anything
without directly interfering in people's
lives or assigning them to potentially
dangerous exposures so why can't we rely
on these studies to establish causal
relationships between substances and
their effects on health the problem is
that even the best conducted
epidemiological studies have inherent
flaws precisely because the test
subjects are not randomly assigned to
their groups for example if the cohort
in our herbal study consisted of people
who took the supplement for health
reasons they may have already had higher
rates of nausea than the other people in
the sample or the cohort group could
have been composed of people who shop at
health food stores and have different
diets or better access to health care
these factors that can affect results in
addition to the factor being studied are
known as confounding variables these two
major pitfalls combined with more
general dangers such as conflicts of
interest or selective use of data can
make the findings of any particular
epidemiological studies suspect and a
good study must go out of its way to
prove that its authors have taken steps
to eliminate these types of errors but
even when this has been done the very
nature of epidemiological studies which
examine differences between pre-existing
groups rather than deliberately inducing
changes within the same individuals
means that a single study can only
demonstrate a correlation between a
substance and a health outcome rather
than a true cause and effect
relationship at the end of the day
epidemiological studies have served as
excellent guides to public health
alerting us to critical health hazards
such as smoking asbestos lead and many
more but these were demonstrated through
multiple well conducted epidemiological
studies all pointing in the same
direction so the next time you see a
headline about a new miracle cure or the
terrible danger posed by an everyday
substance try to learn more about the
original study and the limitations
inherent in any epidemiological study or
clinical trial before jumping to
conclusions
you